round six of the think bill cup  tournament of the year here in st. Louis  it was the day after the rest day and  the world's best players came into the  round refreshed and ready to go all out  for victory world champion Magnus  crosses Preston throat again Takeru  Nakamura  but after 94 moves there was no headway  to be made the game finally ended the  draw Levon Aronian built up a winning  position against branches' Tour champion  Leslie Seoul and the Armenian superstar  crashed through in dominating style to  bring himself back into contention near  the top of the leaderboard  there are only three rounds to go in a  race to the finish line round seven  action coming up now